i really went like full-on pro-islamic
state
um this january when the infighting
syria began
[Music]
social media is the oxygen of publicity
for groups like is
it's important that on every level we
fight back
[Music]
the islamic state a terrorist
organization spreading fear on
social media they understand new digital
platforms and they use sophisticated
tactics
sky news has discovered that as soon as
is supporting twitter accounts are
removed
more are instantly created since may
60 000 twitter accounts supporting is
violence have
opened and despite twitter vowing to
take them offline
almost half were created following the
video of james foley's murder
since the news of stephen sotloff's
murder broke 10 percent of all
references about it on twitter have been
positive
our research using software that scans
the content of social media accounts
set out to understand how the islamic
state spread their propaganda
so effectively abdullah
who wants to remain anonymous has had
two twitter accounts shut down
for posting calls to violence and
graphic imagery so what do you think
your twitter account was suspended
i really went like full-on pro-islamic
state um
this january when the infighting in
syria began i don't think twitter should
spend any account for being pro
something because you know twitter is
supposed to be a platform
for free speech you know even you know
even if it goes against popular opinion
uh it should still be you know a
platform for people to express their
views
there's the manner of the executions
islamically um
it is allowed to kill prisoners there is
nothing wrong with that
remember that the islamic state it goes
by the sharia it doesn't go by the
um by the western laws or the china
conventions
as for beheading itself this is
something that the prophet
prophet himself did and you know we we
take it as a valid view
valid way of killing our enemies uh
today
and you know people can use you know
firing squads as well but beheading this
is more it's more about the shock
that it causes it's to strike fear or
you know
to strike fear and the enemies this
research is believed to be the first
truly quantitative analysis of how
islamic state supporters
are using twitter we worked with
recorded future a web intelligence and
monitoring
company to scan millions of accounts
take this map it may look like abstract
art
but each of these points represents a
twitter account
the lines between them show the volume
of connections
that can help us understand the behavior
of these armchair jihadis
as soon as twitter removes an account
the islamic state supporter creates a
new one with a slightly different
name the other supporters in his network
are quick to retweet it
follow this account it is abu bakr says
a fellow supporter
another one tweets could my old and new
followers please follow this
new account some islam enemies are
trying to have him suspended
twitter is constantly playing catch-up
and so
are other digital platforms along with
the giants like facebook and youtube
the islamic state is also turning to
smaller lesser-known sites to increase
its reach
social media is the oxygen of publicity
for groups like
is it has served their agenda very well
in terms of
recruiting individuals indoctrinating
and brainwashing young impressionable
people it gives them the ability to
upload
material instantaneously to precipitate
the fear factor
visually and it also illustrates how
sophisticated they've been
in getting their message out to a
worldwide
audience and that the fact that they can
control the message themselves they're
not at the mercy
of anybody else the days of al-qaeda
filming a video sending it to a courier
in peshawar
and then waiting for the news media to
broadcast it it's over now you just need
access to a computer
twitter accounts can only be removed if
another user reports them
manually twitter told sky news they
couldn't comment on any
future plans to adopt an automated
system a spokesperson said
twitter users around the world send
approximately 500 million tweets each
day and we do not
monitor them proactively our rules
prohibit unlawful use and violent
threats
and we will take action when users
report violations to us
so should twitter introduce an automated
system for taking down is supporting
accounts
the advantage of using an automated
system is obviously it's
a lot faster than relying on people to
just report tweets or
accounts individually and you know
that's a reactive process
and it it requires looking at everything
on a case-by-case basis
by which point usually things are spread
across the the social media sphere so
quickly that it's it's got out of hand
and an automated system could presumably
do this a lot quicker and maybe
stop things from from going so far in
the first place
until an automated system is in place
the responsibility lies with
users yesterday for example one of the
tweets that i put out was that
they have to stop justifying their evil
in the name of my faith and that has
been retweeted
over a thousand times it's important
that on every level we fight back
and clearly say that this is not in my
name this is not in the name
of islam and that we will not sit back
and tolerate this kind of
action this is an information
war fought online and it's one the
islamic state
is winning tom cheshire sky news